สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วันจันทร์
วันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
กรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
เขียนใหม่ก็ได้ครูฟ้าไม่ได้ดูเป็นเลข 2
โอเค
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 2 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 4
ถึงจะเขียนวันที่ 2 อยู่แล้วนะคะนักเรียน
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลาเที่ยงคืน
เที่ยงคืนนี้
คะ
เที่ยงคืน 9 นาทีค่ะ
เที่ยงคืน 9 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางคืน
เป็นเวลากลางคืนแล้วก็ดึกแล้วเที่ยงคืน
เนี่ยครูฟ้าไปนอนค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงคิดว่าครูฟ้าบอกว่าโอเคปิด
ซูมแล้วก็ไปนอน
ไม่ได้ๆเราไม่ได้หรอกครูหญิงขา
ขา
เที่ยงคืนเนี่ย
กลางคืน
ค่ะ
ตอนกลางคืนเราก็ต้องนอนสิคะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ชอบนอนไง
ใช่แล้วก็แตะผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าตอนนี้ครูฟ้า
อยู่ออสเตรเลียก็เปลี่ยนไปตอนกลางคืน
เนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอนมากขึ้นดีกับร่างกาย
ของเรานะ
จริงเหรอคะคุณหญิง
ทำไมอ่ะเนี่ยอันนี้ครูฟ้าใช่ไหมแล้วก็อัน
นี้คือ
ร่างกายของครูฟ้า
ดูสวยค่ะคุณหญิง
ขอบคุณค่ะ
นี่ขาเล็กๆนะคะ
นี่คือร่างกายของครูฟ้าใช่ไหมดีกับหัวใจ
ดีกับสมองดีกับตาดีกับปากดีกับปอด
ใช่เนี่ยร่างกายของครูฟา
จะดีขึ้นแล้วก็ผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าตอนนี้เป็น
เวลากลางคืนดึกแล้วใช่ไหมคะเที่ยงคืน
เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็อาจจะ
ง่วงนอนผู้หญิงก็เลยมีเกมมีคำถามเนี่ยมา
เล่นกับครูฟ้า
อะไร
ถามเกี่ยวกับร่างกายเนี่ยแหละค่ะครูฟ้า
ถามเกี่ยวกับร่างกายของครูฟ้าตอนเด็กๆ
เนี่ยคิดว่าตอนครูฟ้าอายุสัก 13
เราน่าจะเรียนตั้งแต่อายุเท่าไหร่นะ
เกี่ยวกับร่างกายของเรา
หมดแล้วใช่ไหมคะเกี่ยวกับหัวใจน่าจะอายุ
ประมาณสัก 10 ขวบไหม
ใช่ครูฟ้าเรียนตอน 12
12 ใช่ป่ะผู้หญิงก็เดาว่าอย่างนั้นน่าจะ
ม 1
อายุ 12 ถึงอายุ 18 ใช่ไหมคะ
อ่าเราก็จะเรียนเกี่ยวกับหัวใจ DNA เซลล์
สมองวันนี้เนี่ยหญิงก็จะมีคำถามมาถามครู
ฟ้าค่ะมาเช็คว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยรู้หรือเปล่า
จริงๆผู้หญิงเนี่ยดูหน้าคิด
ไม่รู้แต่ครูฟ้าเขาก็ Amazing อยู่นะคะ
นักเรียน
บางเรื่องเขาก็ IQ ดีมากผู้หญิงก็แบบ
เรามาดูคำถามแรกเลยนะคะครูฟ้ารู้ไหมคะว่า
อันนี้อะไร
นี่คือ
ปอดค่ะ
คำถามก็คือในร่างกายของเราเนี่ยเรามีปอด
เท่าไหร่
1 หรือ 2 คะครูฟ้า
ร่างกายของเราเนี่ยมีปอด
เท่าไหร่หรอคะใช่
เอาไว้ทำอะไรคะผู้หญิง
ใช่ค่ะ
เพราะเราหายใจที่จมูกแล้วมันก็จะลงไปที่
ปอดของเรา
เราก็เลย
มี
ปอด 2 ข้างค่ะ
ครูฟ้าบอกว่า 2 ใช่ไหมคะมาดูซิว่าครูฟ้า
ตอบถูกหรือว่าตอบผิดด้วย
เราอาจจะคิดว่า 1 ก็ได้ไงรวมเป็นหนึ่งแต่
จริงๆ
2 ค่ะ 1 ถุง
ใช่ค่ะข้อต่อไปนะคะข้อต่อไปเนี่ยเป็นคำ
ถามเกี่ยวกับฟันนะฟันอันนี้คือฟันนะคะนัก
เรียนฟันส่วนสีชมพูสีส้มๆชมพูแดงๆที่นัก
เรียนเห็นเนี่ยเราเรียกอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เหงือกค่ะ
ครูฟ้ามีเหงือก
มองไม่เห็น
นั่นคือฟันใช่ไหมคะคำถามก็คือเวลาที่เรา
เป็นเด็กใช่ไหมเราเป็นเด็กเนี่ยเราเกิดมา
เราอายุเท่าไหร่เราจะเริ่มมีฟันน่าจะ
ประมาณ
1 ขวบไหม
1 ขวบมีฟันแล้วหรอ
มีแล้วนะมี 1 ซี่แล้วนะ
คะเราจะมีฟันเนี่ย
20 ซี่ใช่ไหมคะอันนี้เราเรียกว่านัก
เรียนหญิง
ใช่ไหมคะเวลาเราเป็นเด็กเนี่ยฟันชุดที่ 1
เนี่ยมี 20 ซี่แต่เวลาที่เราตกขึ้นโตขึ้น
ฟันชุดที่ 1 เนี่ยหลุดหลุดหมดแล้วเราจะมี
ฟันชุดที่ 2 ฟันชุดที่ 2 ของเราเนี่ยมี
กี่ซี่คะครูฟ้า
ฟันชุดที่ 2 ของเรา
มี 28 ซี่
30ซี่หรือว่า 32  C เนี่ยครูหญิงก็มีฟัน
ชุดที่ 2 แล้วโตแล้วใช่ไหมครูฟ้าก็มีฟัน
ชุดที่ 2
ไม่ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าไม่ใช่เด็กแล้วนะคะ
เราอายุเท่าไหร่อ่ะ
7 ขวบไหมเราก็เริ่ม
พอเรา 7 ขวบฟันชุดที่ 1 ก็หลุดเราเริ่มมี
ชุดที่ 2 แล้วป่ะ
เราเรียกว่า
ใช่ฟันชุดที่ 1 ใช่ไหมที่มี 20 ซี่เนี่ย
เราเรียกว่าอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ฟันน้ำนม
ปั่นน้ำนมเนี่ยมันจะหลุดใช่ไหมหลุดพอมี
ฟันชุดที่ 2 ก็คือฟันแท้
ไม่แล้วนะคะนอกจากเราไม่แปรงฟันมีกี่ซี่
และครูฟ้า
[ปรบมือ]
เวลาคุณตอบไม่ต้องแช่มๆๆค่ะเวลาดิฉันเฉลย
พลอยทำๆๆ
ปันชุดที่ 2 นะคะ
มีทั้งหมด 3
10  2  8 อันนี้คืออะไรคะ
ลอตเตอรี่นะคะ
[เพลง]
ไม่ได้ค่ะคุณต้องเลือก 1 ข้อค่ะ 28  30
หรือว่า 32
ครูฟ้าเลือก
32 ค่ะ
32 นะคะมาดูว่าครูฟ้าจะตอบถูกหรือเปล่า
[เพลง]
เก่งมาก
โอเคคำถามข้อที่ 3 นะคะฟันเหงือกนะปอด
เนี่ยนะคะหรือว่า
หูตาจมูกปากหัวใจเนี่ยนะคะทั้งหมดที่อยู่
ในร่างกายของเราเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้า
อวัยวะ
ใช่ไหมอวัยวะก็จะมีข้างนอกน้องที่นัก
เรียนมองเห็นใช่ไหมตาจมูกปากแล้วก็มีข้าง
ใน
ปอดเนี่ยเป็นอวัยวะข้างในอวัยวะภายในเรา
เนี่ยมองไม่เห็นเนาะต้องเอกซเรย์นะคะ
คำถามก็คือเอาอวัยวะเนี่ยเรามีเยอะใช่ไหม
คะมีทั้งอวัยวะที่เล็กอวัยวะที่ใหญ่คำถาม
ข้อนี้จะถามว่าครูฟ้าคิดว่าอวัยวะอะไร
อวัยวะชิ้นไหนที่ใหญ่ที่สุดในร่างกายเรา
แต่ไม่เอาอันนี้นะอันนี้คือผิวหนังผิวผิว
หนังเนี่ยมันใหญ่มันก็เป็นอวัยวะเนอะ
ใช่ๆบางคนก็บอกนะแต่ไม่เอาผิวหนังนะบอก
ไว้ก่อนเผื่อนักเรียนจะคิดว่าเอ๊ะผิวหนัง
เป็นอวัยวะที่ใหญ่ที่สุดไม่เอาผิวหนังนะ
คะ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าอะไรมีหัวใจ
สมองแล้วก็ตับอวัยวะชิ้นไหนใหญ่ที่สุดใน
ร่างกายเรา
อวัยวะที่ใหญ่ที่สุด
หัวใจนะคะ
หัวใจครูฟ้าเคยได้ยินว่าหัวใจเนี่ยจะเท่า
มือเรา
ถ้าหัวใจเราเนาะก็เท่ากำปั้นของเราใช่ไหม
เข้ามือของเราเวลาเราแบบนี้นะ
เรากำมือหัวใจก็จะเท่ามือเรา
ผู้หญิงแค่นี้เองหรอ
หัวใจเล็กเหรอ
ไม่ใช่
หัวใจที่ใหญ่ที่สุดในร่างกาย
สมอง
มีไหม
ทำไมคะครูฟ้าหัวใหญ่มากนะสมองครูฟ้าก็อาจ
จะใหญ่เท่าขนาดหัวก็ได้
สมองกูฟ้ามีนิดนึง
ได้ค่ะ
[เพลง]
เป็นอวัยวะภายในทั้งหมดเนาะอวัยวะที่ใหญ่
เนี่ยมันจะอยู่ภายในร่างกายเราครูฟ้าคิด
ว่าอะไรคะอวัยวะชิ้นไหนที่ใหญ่ที่สุดใน
ร่างกายของเรา
เลือกอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
ตรงไหนคะ
อะไรนะคะ
ตับค่ะ
ตับนะคะครูฟ้าตอบว่าตับคืออวัยวะที่ใหญ่
ที่สุดในร่างกายใช่
ทำๆๆ
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยข้อที่ 1 ถูกข้อที่ 2
ก็ถูกข้อที่ 3 ก็ถูกแต่ว่าสมองของครูฟ้า
ไม่เล็กนะคะน่าจะประมาณนี้
คำถามข้อต่อไปนะคะคำถามเนี่ยข้อนี้เนี่ย
ถามใหญ่แล้วใช่ไหมคำถามข้อที่ 4 นะคะถาม
ว่า
อวัยวะชิ้นไหนที่หนักที่สุดในร่างกายเรา
น้ำหนักเนี่ยก็อาจจะเป็นกิโลกรัมที่
ประเทศไทยนะคะแต่ถ้าบางประเทศก็อาจจะเป็น
ปอนด์หรือว่าใช้ LP นะจำไม่ได้แล้วอ่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรนะเอาแบบประเทศไทยดีกว่าเนาะน้ำ
หนักนะคะอวัยวะชิ้นไหนที่หนักที่สุดใน
ร่างกายเราเหมือนเดิมนะคะนักเรียนไม่เอา
ผิวหนังว่าถ้าเราผิวหนังมารวมกันแล้วชั่ง
มีตาชั่งใช่ไหม
เป็นตาชั่งมันเป็นอย่างนี้ป่ะ
ใช่ค่ะ
1  2  3 เป็นตาชั่งเอามาวาง
หนักเนี่ยผิวหนังเนี่ยมันหนักที่สุดไม่
เอาผิวหนังนะคะ
คิดว่าอวัยวะชิ้นไหนคะเหมือนเดิมนะคะตับ
กลับมาอีกแล้ว
ปอดหรือสมองอวัยวะชิ้นไหนที่หนักที่สุดใน
ร่างกายเรา
หัวใจ
หัวใจไม่มี
หัวใจมันเท่ากำปั้นไงวันนี้ไม่เอาหัวใจ
แล้ว
เปลี่ยนครูฟ้าขอตอบว่า
ตับค่ะ
ทำไมคะทำไมครูฟ้าตอบว่าตับเพราะว่าตับ
เป็นอวัยวะที่ใหญ่แล้วนะจะหนักอีกหรอ
ก็มันใหญ่ไงมันก็เลยนะเบสิค
เห็นไหมครูฟ้าไม่ใช่แค่นี้นะแค่นี้
มาดูกันว่าครูฟ้าจะตอบถูกหรือเปล่าทั้งๆๆ
[เพลง]
เก่งมาก
แล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ตับ
หนัก
ประมาณนะประมาณ
กี่กิโลกรัมหนักเท่าไหร่
ครูฟ้าว่า
ตอบถูก
เก่งค่ะแค่นั้นแหละ
ผู้หญิงไม่มีอะไรให้ครูฟ้าตอบถูกนะคะก็
แค่เก่ง
ว่าประมาณ 1-2 กิโลกรัม
นะประมาณ
1-2
กิโลกรัมนะคะมาดูว่า
ปอดไม่ใช่ปอดขอโทษค่ะปอดคืออันนี้นะคะไม่
ใช่ปอดนะ
cancel นะคะพอร์ตคืออันนี้นะคะตับเนี่ย
เท่าไหร่
กิโลกรัม
แต่อันนี้แล้วแต่แล้วแต่ร่างกายของคนใช่
ค่ะแล้วจริงๆแล้วสมอง
สมองก็ใกล้ๆกับตับนะคือสมองเนี่ยเบาเบา
กว่าตับนิดเดียวจริงๆนะคะนิดเดียวคิดว่า
สมองเรามันมีน้ำเยอะอ่ะเนาะ
แต่ปอดนะคะเบามากๆนี่แหละค่ะก็เป็นคำถาม
วันนี้ครูฟ้าเก่งมากนะคะผู้หญิงถาม 4 ข้อ
ครูฟ้าถูกทุกข้อเลยเก่งมากๆนะคะแต่ว่า
วีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วไงคะครูฟ้าแต่ว่านัก
เรียนก็รู้แล้วนะคะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเรียน
หนังสือมาจำได้เก่งมากนะคะเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอ
กันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้าอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เปล่าค่ะ
งั้นปรบมือให้ครูฟ้า 3 ครั้งนะคะ 1  2  3
เก่งมากบ๊ายบายค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ